Wow, hello everybody!
Hello, hello, hello.
Welcome to the... Oh my gosh, I'm listening to my study.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
The Doki Loop, babe.
Oh my gosh, where is it?
Where is it coming from?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I was like, the Doki Loop.
Where is it coming from?
Junior.
But everyone, welcome to the Niki stream.
Yes, we're in my little spooky room right now because it's almost spooky month.
Yes.
And to celebrate spooky month, Goddess of Victory Niki is doing a very special collaboration with Resident Evil.
So a huge shout out to Niki for sponsoring me for today's stream.
If you click on the link pinned in the description, It really does help out a lot with the sponsor and the stream.
So yeah, check out the link pinned in the chat and in the description.
It helps out a lot.
But yes, there's a lot of new updates in Niki.
Not only is there a new Resident Evil collab, there's a new skins, there's a new skin, there's new characters dropping out, dropping that you can pull for that is related to Resident Evil.
There is also, I think there's like a new mini-game and a new story as well that's related to Resident Evil.
So it's all very exciting.
But yes, please feel free to download, re-download, enter the game, click on the link, and enjoy the Nikkei X Resident Evil collab.
Yay!
I'm super excited.
You guys might notice I have several outfits and props on right now because it is based off of...
pull it up um one of their newest character oh not new character what are newest outfits uh for one of their characters let me pull it pull it out yes originally um the intro was just gonna be me on top of her like me on top of her but i was like no no we'll save that for later you guys will get your fan service later yes let me uh this is based off of her i'm believe her name is wait for killer what the killer wife i was like i had to i had to look i have to like reread like wait wait oh d killer wife yeah killer d what yes so this is her new her new outfit and you see i have her hat right now You had to,
like, I had to do, like, a second look at it, like, a double take, because I was like, wait, am I reading?
D for Doki, yes, Doki Killer Wife, yeah, because I have her baton pen, like, and her hat on right now, but you can actually pull for her costume right now, to celebrate the new collab, I think it looks, I mean, it looks really good, like, I think my favorite,
oh my, there's so many, I don't know, Oh my gosh, I have to pick.
I really like her jacket, though.
I like the jacket hang-off vibe to it.
It adds more to the silhouette and everything.
I mean, there's a lot of assets to enjoy with the new costume.
And as again, thank you again for the sponsor, Nike.
I really appreciate it.
I'm super excited to check out the new Resident Evil collab.
I believe you can pull several characters.
I think there's going to be Jill.
You can pull Jill later.
But right now, you can pull for Ada.
believe it's Jill, Ada, and Claire.
Yeah.
So I believe one of them, uh, Claire, you can get it through the events.
Um, but yeah, you can pull for Jill.
Yeah, the Jill.
Yeah, you can get, you can get a Jill sandwich later.
Um, but yeah, I'm pretty excited to try out like the host camp new, the new story event and the new mini game.
Apparently it's a mini game as well.
it.
Alright, let's move to before we, before we check out the game, I do have a video that I want to watch real quick or react to super duper quick.
I think it's to celebrate the promotion of the event itself, so let me pull it up.
Where is it?
Here it is.
Ooh, spooky.
I haven't watched this yet.
There's some Oh my god, there you guys are, dragoons.
There you guys are.
I think you guys are trying to summon me.
Spooky.
Oh, they're entering the house.
That's you.
Yeah, so that is the announcement for the...
Yeah, it's the mansion.
Yeah, I was like, oh my god, that's the mansion.
But it's pretty exciting.
I don't know, really, I'm going in blind regarding what the collab, uh, what the collab is in terms of like what the story is, what the mini game is.
So it's gonna be super exciting to check out, um, check all of it out together with you guys.
Uh, all right.
Let's get right into it.
All right.
Before we do play the mini game and the story, obviously we gotta pull for, we gotta do, we gotta pull for Ada.
We have to before we do anything else.
Like she has to be there.
I swear to her, she has to be there.
This time, this time, I'll get her.
This time, we will get her for real.
I swear to God, we will get Ada for real this time.
We will obtain the assets.
I think I can do it in 20 pulls.
Knowing, even though I didn't cleanse my bad luck in a long...
I still haven't done it, guys.
I still haven't done it.
But this time, it doesn't include gotcha.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure we'll be fine.
I believe...
I need you guys to also believe in me, okay, chat?
If you guys don't believe in me, we can't make it work.
So I need you to also believe in me as well.
So then we can have Ada as part of our little collection.
I think we can do it in 20 polls.
I think it's possible.
All right, let's see.
We can do it.
Yeah, believe in me that believes in you.
All right, there you go.
There's Ada right here.
There she is.
Oh, yeah.
Sound guy.
Let me know if that's...
Oh, wait.
I realized the sound was not playing when I was...
The sound guy.
Let me know if everything is okay.
I just gotta make sure.
Uh...
Alright.
Yay, claim all.
Claim all.
Whenever I tab out, the sound disappears.
I don't know why.
Okay, so that's the story of it.
Look, I still have her.
I still have little mermaid.
I think I pull...
I don't even remember how many times it took me to pull her.
But I think it was once, right?
I say as I cope.
I mean, I pull everything in one tribe.
That's how lucky I am, right?
all right but let's do this i believe yes uh you can basically pull for ada right now um and there's you know you have 26 days left to pull for her so yeah all right we can do this what do i just do one okay i have two free i can do two two pulls i think it did in one try
I think I could pull her in two tries I think I think I could pull her in two tries I saw that I was like What are your orders
Oh my god not her Oh my god, not you guys.
I already have all of you.
Nice to meet you.
Soldier F.A.
Oh my god, I don't want you default and these.
Get out of here!
You're never gonna be used anyway.
Get out!
Alright, guys, I think you can pull them one in two tries.
Oh.
Alright, this time.
Nice to meet you.
Never mind.
It gave me a little pause.
I thought that was when it starts glowing.
I was like, oh my god, it's going to glow.
And then it's like, nope, that's it.
That's all you're going to get.
Oh my god, not the goddamn nerd.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
buttons to trigger the streamer luck.
Yaki, thank you for the Aka soup.
It's fine.
Wait, how many?
How many do I have left?
Oh, I can do one.
Okay.
I think I could do it.
I think I could get her in three tries.
I think I can do it in three tries, guys.
Whoa.
Guys, it's gone.
It's gone.
You know what that means?
Wait, it glowed.
It glowed gold.
That has to be her.
to be here go find something delicious old timer okay no nice to meet you and two more all right next one after her after the nerd after the nerd is it is it come on i teacher it's been ages i I missed you so much.
I don't remember this recent evil character.
Wait, which game is she from, guys?
Guys, guys, it's her, right?
Soldier F.A.
I thought you were gonna be a turkey sandwich.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sonic.
It's...
It's okay.
I have...
Guys, I think... Oh, I can... Oh, wait, I have...
I have gems.
Okay.
I think you can pull in four tries.
I think... Alright.
Okay.
Wait!
What?!
The name's Ada.
we're after the same thing.
What?
Oh my god.
Why did it go purple?
What?
I thought it wasn't...
It faded me.
I thought it was purple.
I was like, oh, it's purple.
It's nothing.
I didn't go all the way.
I got it.
It's fine.
We got it.
They didn't mean the thing.
I was like, oh, it's nothing.
Trash.
This is true.
I told you.
I told you, Chad, I could get it in four tries.
Finally, not hard pity.
Finally.
Oh my god, she was the last one too.
That purple is the lucky color.
Oh my god.
Let's check out Ada.
operative who never reveals vulnerability no matter the circumstances Ada works alone stayed laser focused on her mission and keeping emotional ties at bay her true motives and identity and loyalty remains shrouded in secrecy even the name Ada won is just a an alias I can't believe it she baited oh my god there's her other oh there's them there's her other outfits I remember I don't remember this one but I remember this oh that's so cool there's her other like like uh resident evil outfits too wait she uses a bow that's interesting i thought she'd be like i thought she would use like her her uh pistol uh her pistol but like i mean it's cool because like i don't think any of the niki characters uses a bow too yeah it's an explosive uh crossbow too oh all right what is this oh okay the tv is cute i like i i think i love the Nikkei Chibis.
Yeah.
Oh, it's because like Jill uses a pistol.
I guess that makes sense because you know like they want to have like each character has their own um, has their own uh, guns, like different types of uh, weapon.
So like I guess it makes sense for her to have the explosive crossbow to differentiate.
I love the Chibis.
I think the Chibis are so cute.
Is that the hotel that D manages?
Hmm.
all right wait do you think i can see do they have uh jill and claire already in the uh thing okay see i told you guys i told i'll bring it down a little yeah no problem all right i'll bring the volume down a little bit see you guys i told you i can get it in four thank gosh whoa sorry thank thank god because i actually i ran out of money all right
with a super chat thank you thank you duchess dokeybird please do my post for me on all my accounts please i'll give you whatever you want mr broken bond thank you for the super chat thank you yeah that was a that was a flashbang i just wanted to check the other stuff and i was like flashbang i was like whoa whoa okay uh it's like oh did you expect to see this a pakistan
Oh, welcome back.
Wait, I gotta clean, guys.
I gotta do my dailies real quick, chat.
This is very important.
Wait, don't get to you missed something.
Go back.
No, guys, we gotta move on.
Oh, yeah.
I got really worried because I was like, you know, I've been very unlucky lately, so I was like, should I maybe I should farm some more gems just in case thank god I actually was farming gems um last night just in case just in case it did not take the it did not take two tries thank god because the last poll I did was literally all my free gems that was all it went to I assume the...
Oh, there it is.
So for the costume gotcha, you can pull it for the...
For the killer wave.
For the...
For...
Sorry, I lost my train of thought.
I don't know why.
For the new costume for the killer wave.
So it's the secret blue skin.
See, I'm wearing her hat right now.
And I'll have her baton stick.
Alright.
So you get free pull right now.
Spin, spin, spin, spin!
We're offering great discounts.
Don't miss them.
Oh, yeah.
Is that a costume?
No!
That's a costume, right?
Well, I didn't know they could fit the entire costume in that briefcase, guys.
Oh, my God.
We got...
Oh, I could...
I mean, I could see it.
What's her...
killer wife.
I guess I have to go to the Pedia.
Uh, killer wife.
Umon.
This is what she looks like.
Wait, what does she looks like when she's shooting?
Oh, is it one shot?
Oh, it is.
Oh, I forgot you can move him like this while shooting.
What about the chibi?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, she's like a cross card for the special.
Oh, it's a sniper.
Okay, that makes sense.
I thought it would be like...
Because it doesn't look... I guess...
Okay, never mind.
I see.
I forgot.
This is the scope.
I was like, oh, it doesn't look like a sniper.
Nope, there's a giant-ass scope on top of it.
Yeah, she's a little traffic cop.
What else is the other one?
Okay, we'll look at Jill and Claire later.
All right, let's check out.
Guys, which one does the minigame?
I want to check out the Resident Evil minigame.
Great design personality is so evil.
I mean, if someone is named the killer wife, I would assume.
I would, you know, if their name is the killer wife, I would assume that they are not...
a good person, because I don't think a good person would name themselves Killer Wife.
Yeah, I heard the minigame is super addicting.
Now for, alright, let's check it out.
Apparently, you have to go through the story first for it.
Now, for the next report, over the past few days, a series of missing person cases have been reported across the arc.
The central government has issued an official statement.
saying that the incidents cannot be classified as serial disappearances.
Click, click.
Case number one.
Missing person, Miles Carter.
Mill, 45, former commander.
183 centimeters, 80 kilogram.
Last seen leaving his home around 11 p.m.
His daughter filed a report with the ACPU two days after his disappearance.
Notable information.
lost his leg during operation on the surface and has a long history of alcohol abuse recently began counseling at the urgent urging of his daughter those around him say he had been showing improvement and was two months into sobriety counseling which counseling center confirmation required is that john nikke meanwhile the rap the rapture okay sorry i'm sorry the rapture part discovered at the home of the missing person was said to be debris from destroyed from a unit destroying using uh the recent terrorist attack on the ark and the central government has declared that it is unrelated to current missing person's case however some has raised suspicion of a cover-up feeling ongoing controversy click click it's a different ratchet case number four missing person iris monroe female 68 former nurse jesus she must have made so much as a nurse oh my god i didn't realize nurses i thought nurses don't get paid that much but
oh my god yeah i know it's like how how 154 cm wait she's 68 Okay, she looks good.
Last seen around 10 a.m.
after leaving to a gathering with acquaintances.
Around 7 p.m.
on the same day, her son filed a report with the ACPU.
Authorities visited her residence immediately after the report was filled, but it was empty.
Preliminary findings that deceased I can't believe she's 68.
Suggest the entire family has gone missing.
Clay's classified as a family disappearance.
Notable information.
No signs of forced entry.
A rapture part was found in the basement.
A gathering of acquaintances?
Unable to verify details.
The rapture part was placed on some kind of altar.
For what purpose?
Conspiracy theory is suggesting that the groundwork is being laid for a second ARC terror attack.
Feeling widespread anxiety among the general populace.
Click click.
Case number eight.
Oh my gosh, we're already at eight?
What happened to the other numbers?
Missing person.
Elzeria nine.
I swear, she's like 95 or something.
Female.
Okay, sorry.
42 is still pretty.
Oh my god, what is going on in this world of Niki?
And where can I get in it?
Psychological counselor.
167 CM, 55 KGU.
Exact time of disappearance.
Unknown.
What are they feeding them?
Reported missing to the ACPU by our last client.
Noble information.
operated a counseling center confirmed to be same center where Miles Carter underwent counseling has a daughter named de para no contact with the daughter as of yet also missing why did the daughter fail to report her mother's disappear yeah that is pretty weird your mom's missing why did you not report anything do you not love her click This is not good.
Holi puts the pen down.
Ah.
Well, these eyes shift from the case file to the computer monitor beside her.
At a partisan, partition, leading to the outer rim.
They have a drug in the art called evergreen or eternal life that slows down aging.
That's why Ingrid looks in her 30s despite being in her...
What?
Yo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god, the wonder.
I was like, oh my, this is a 65 year old nurse.
First off, you are in a very stressful environment.
The face of the girl captured on CCTV was...
Dei Parra.
Oh, it's the daughter.
Oh, she...
Oh, I like her outfit.
I really like her outfit.
like her outfit.
Girl, I don't know if you're evil or not, but you're...
You have good fashion sense.
That is a nice outfit.
It was unmistakably a day para.
As identified in the file for case number eight.
Your fit is fire, though.
This is the only lead we've got.
Can't afford to lose this trail now.
Right.
Can't afford to lose this trail at all.
I'm gonna like the self.
I'm gonna save it I'm gonna I'm gonna save your fit real quick
Okay, Polly grabs her side art Hope it's I hope there's nothing serious Yoink she sets off from the police station
Missing pretty what?
Come on!
Wait, we were just with her!
Where did she go?
She was just there!
ECPU investigate.
She's just gone, I guess.
She's...
Went missing during the investigation.
Did she get lost in the way?
Like, do we have a GPS on her?
Where's her tracking?
Wait, if she's a Niki, don't we have, like, a tracker tag on her?
I don't know.
I feel like, if, you know, when you have like cyborg like you know you know cyborg slash android's i feel like you put a tracker on them like a find your iphone find your nikki yeah i feel like that would be smart right like an air tag find your nikki i must find these people cut to the person being missing confirm last scene I feel like that would make sense,
right?
Have a fine Unique?
All signs point to her pursuing Dapara alone.
Notable information.
Confirmed I visited a counseling center operated by 9 on the day of her disappearance.
The center is currently decommissioned.
Entry is not permitted.
Recently, a phrase has been reported to be circulating among the staff.
umbrella will pave the way for it for us oh my god that's where umbrella comes in wait does that mean umbrella has their own nikki as well
freeborn evil
oh we're in the mansion oh that's so cool
all right story one i assume is challenge oh wait wait what's this Touch your salvation doctrine.
You who have lost your way need not grieve.
The judge already guides humanity towards salvation.
Foolish human.
Do not resist.
Oh, there's a typewriter!
I can log in.
Okay, I'll claim it.
Yoink.
Mine now.
There's like supply blocks.
What's this?
Suspicious area.
What's over here?
I assume...
Okay.
I have to reach chapter 5.
Oh, is Claire in here?
Is she in here?
Where is she?
Oh, it's for mats.
Okay.
No.
Oh, it's like part of the...
Oh, she's the login bonus.
Let me check.
I want to look at it.
Oh, there she is.
Okay, it's the third day.
Claire Redfield is a college student who ventured into Raccoon City to find her brother, Chris.
She's one of the few survivors of the Raccoon City incident.
One of the deadliest pandemics in history.
Okay, so it's on the third day.
So on your third login, you should be able to get...
tomorrow that's cool i'm glad you can get clear like early on too that's nice oh i got my herb all right so i did play till chapter five to unlock the oh mixed herbs what's the mixed herbs for okay i have ada oh i forgot okay do i need okay guys i need a guys before i continue Girl,
my new girl.
This is why I also farmed.
Where's Ada?
Exactly why I farmed.
There we go.
That's right.
Eat up, Ada.
Yum, yum.
Eat up.
I do.
I farmed it just for this.
Alright, also I gotta grab the outpost real quick.
Eat up, girl.
I got fattened you up.
Alright.
So you can be big and strong like all my other Nikes.
You gotta be strong for me.
Exclamation point feed.
Okay, nice.
I want to see if I'm stronger than before.
Care to take a little...
Om yam yam yam.
Okay, now we can go back in.
All right, now we can go in just in case.
All right, five out of five.
Enter.
Event number one.
Can I auto?
Okay, auto.
Wait, what about Ada?
Get out of here!
Ada only!
What if I just...
What if?
Wait, can I send just her in?
Wait, I can!
Wait, it's possible.
This is my Ada only run.
Right on time.
Take a seat.
I heard a D-wave was detected.
Yes.
It was two weeks ago.
A D-wave triggered by the entity code named Gatekeeper was picked up.
Two weeks ago, you said?
Why wasn't I notified immediately we have to confirm a few things the d wave wasn't detected on the surface this time it came from inside the arc huh we're presently picking up d-wave signals from a mansion located in the elder rim if we move too hastily there's a risk of the d-wave being exposed external priorities.
This could reignite tensions with the Elder Rim, especially since the dust has only just settled from the last Elder Rim incident.
As such, the central government has decided to handle this case with extreme caution.
Which brings me to my point.
Have you ever heard of the Torch of Salvation?
The Torch of Salvation?
I've heard it before when I was working for a case helping that girl, Deepara, searched for a mother.
Aren't they the cult that worships raptures as gods?
It seems you're well informed.
Take a look at this.
Anderson hands me a document.
The document reads, Human life falls into oblivion, throwing a world into turmoil.
New life has been created, a cruel distortion of all things sacred.
Merciless judges descend from the sky.
Do not resist why thy feeble human strength.
The end is nigh.
God.
Guide these foolish mortals to their reckoning.
Is this a prayer?
Where did we recover this near the mansion where the D-wave was detected.
It's supposedly a prayer recited at the touch at the torch of salvation, gathering, and also, that mansion has been identified as a gathering site for the Torch of Salvation.
We shouldn't go charging in head first, unless we want a complete fiasco on our hands.
The most reliable method is to infiltrate their ranks by posing as a believer.
That's why we spent the past two weeks gathering all available intel on the Torch of Salvation.
Yay!
We're going to join a cult!
trade undercover we're gonna be so undercover we're very good at being undercover cops remember guys what your task is simple memorize the materials we've compiled disguise yourself as a believer of the torch yeah disguise wow sir how did you know that's what my favorite uh my favorite groups my favorite my favorite book club then enter the mansion investigate the or guided the D wave.
While you're there, resolve any related incidents you encounter.
You want me to go undercover?
I've heard a lot about your infiltration skills.
Where it is, you use that skill to close the book on several major cases.
We're counting on you to put those skills to get used once more.
Just so you know, the counters won't be a you on this mission.
Moving around the outer rim with such prominent individuals poses too great a risk.
Instead, we've arranged a separate support group.
Return to the commander's room.
You'll meet them there.
They'll brief you on the remaining mission details.
Deputy Chief, are you saying?
that'll be all i have a very important meeting to attend well then i look forward to hearing good news from you all right yay i get to go to a book club all right aida no you got this my aida only run if she's op These guys are quite persistent.
I know, right, Ada?
If only you had backup.
Wait, actually, what am I doing?
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
This is starting to get old.
What am I doing?
Ada only, baby.
Let's go.
What do you mean?
She's literally full HP.
She is the backup.
Look at that.
It's fine.
They do, like, one damage to her.
No, that's...
The lure.
She's a solo act.
Next mission together.
Alright.
Yeah, she has AoE.
Oh, nice.
I got mixed herbs.
That's good.
Slow and steady wins the race.
Zing.
He said to meet them back at the commanders room.
but
it's awfully quiet in there guess I'll just sit and wait I sink into the couch and everything Anderson just told me comes flooding back the D wave the outer rim the mansion and the torch of salvation my favorite book club never thought I thought I hear that name again.
They got a little too serious with their books, so I had to leave.
A memory of something I saw on the surface hits me abruptly.
A small altar in the middle of a clearing and a blade of unknown purpose.
People lying around as if they're asleep.
Each of them holding a rapture part in their hands.
I realize I've been entrusted with a mission far greater than I anticipated.
My mind is racing.
Maybe a splash of water would help clear my head.
Drip, drip.
The sound of a running faucet can be heard from the bathroom.
I forgot to turn off the water?
Silly me.
A rapi finds out wait, intruder?
Drip?
Oh my god.
Aggressive drip.
Drip.
Drip, drip.
Huh?
My nose burns i glanced at the mirror and see blood flowing just like the people i saw near the altar back then it's scary drip drip drip drip drip no not the scary drip blood fills the sink oh my god did she just come out of my Where did she come from?
How did she get here?
Aren't you being a bit traumatic?
Wait, there's more than her?
I thought you'd be used to you'd be used to this by now.
Wait, how did she get here?
From my shower?
Huff.
What the?
Hey, you okay?
The blood that filled the sink has completely vanished.
I danced back in the mirror again d oh my god is that d killer wife d and k are standing behind me yeah i'm fine wait what's in the back it's moving so you are no that's regular d no just d wait there's more than oh d original oh so it's like d killer wife is like the upgrade of d or is it like d but eviler yeah oh so it's evil d it's like her evil twin so you're you all are the backup Anderson was talking about we'll wait outside pull yourself together and come out when you're ready d the regular government worker hi this is d the white collar the white collar office worker and then D,
killer white.
As missing persons, reports continue to pour in.
The central government has stated it will take firm action against those who spread false information.
D and double D.
After watching my face, I stepped out and see the news is on.
D is leaning against the wall with her arms crossed.
K is sprawled out on the couch.
They're watching the news.
with grim expressions these days all you hear on TV are stories about people going missing I was told to get submission details directly from both of you stop read that first we'll talk after he tosses a stack of documents onto a table then glances back at the news broadcast looks like I won't get a word out of her until I'm finished with the entire pile.
At the very top of the stack of documents, it reads, Case number one, Missing Person, Miles Carter.
Oh, I read this already.
I guess that was like from the intro, I guess from Polly's perspective.
You're a fast reader.
Now tell me, what exactly is happening in the arc?
As the question hangs in the air, what is in your bag?
It's like moving on its own.
Are you sure you're not D-Killer wife?
My eyes remain fixed on the last page of the document.
Case number nine.
Missing person, Paulie.
Central government is trying to keep it hush-hush.
Plus, as you've just seen, there's been a string of disappearances inside the arc.
The missing persons are all of different ages, genders, and backgrounds.
One of them is even Anike.
At first glance, that doesn't seem to be any obvious links between them.
Case slides a document towards me.
Case number eight.
Missing person, Elseria 9.
Noble information has a daughter named Deepara.
According to central government records, Deepara's mother, Elseria 9, was involved with a cult called the Torch of Salvation.
So, I poked around the counseling center she ran.
It turns out every single missing person is somehow connected to that place.
For example, this guy.
Miles Carter.
Turns out he was going there for counseling.
Ars Monroe used to work there as a nurse.
Not only that, enough you don't have to spell everything out it's all in the documents that I just made him read stupid if if you say so anyway here's the bottom line every one of the missing it is tied to Saria 9 which brings us to the problem she's part of a cult that worships raptures so So,
here's where the D-Wave is coming from.
The first person to go missing, Mouse Carter, vanished two weeks ago.
Strangely enough, we picked a D-Wave coming from the other rim two weeks ago as well.
Right at the mansion where the torch of salvation holds is scattering.
Something about this reeks, wouldn't you agree?
cases, the D-Wave and the Torch of Salvation.
Is this Transcendental connected?
That's right.
This mission's a lot more complex than the last.
We gotta figure out why the D-Wave is being detected from the mansion.
Get to the bottom of how it ties into the disappearance.
Verify the identities of all the missing.
And on top of everything else, rescue them if possible.
Wait, and they're coming with me right?
right naturally if we uncover anything else felonious on the torch of salvation while we're at it we'll have to decide whether or not to eliminate them simple enough so torch of salvation are our target this time around huh okay thank god i was gonna be like are they just sending me by myself like you have guns that's what we were told usual,
you and D will handle the infiltration.
Just pose as...
Oh!
That's my killer wife!
Just pose as a married couple who have been brainwashed by the cult and attend one of their gatherings.
Oh my god, score!
And what will you be doing?
I'll go solo again this time.
I've got a bad feeling about something.
So I want to look into it first.
All right, now that you've been briefed on the mission, Lop, start by memorizing what's written there.
V tosses another stack of documents onto a table, then turns back to the news broadcast.
Once again, it seems she won't say another word until I read through everything.
Just from skimming through, it looks like this is a backstory of the couple we're supposed to play.
Rather than have a backstory, why can't we just, you know, make it up as we go along?
What do you mean to memorize all of this?
I'm off to handle some stuff.
We could improv.
We're good improvers.
Let's give this all or all.
Yeah, you know, we should actually get married for actual immersion too.
What did they check our tax records as a married couple?
We have to share bank accounts as well.
What if we check our marital records?
We gotta commit.
All right, nice.
We cleared it.
All right, okay, guys.
I don't think I can...
All right, unfortunately, it seems like it won't let me do a solo run of Ada.
Looks like you could use some help.
All right, let's do this.
I think, guys, you think we're gonna beat the stage?
Man, I hope we can beat the stage, guys.
I'm just...
I hope we can make it.
Oh my god, they died before they can spawn on my screen.
God, I'm so good at this game.
Um, hello?
I am spectating Ada 1.
Get out of here.
Nice.
I should start preparing for the next class.
Yay!
More mixed herbs.
I'm so good at Niki.
Wow, that was so close, guys.
What a close game.
Their husband and wife.
Both of them come from the Quadidian class.
And have been living a fairly uneventful life in the Ark.
Anette works as a nurse.
On the other hand, her husband...
Speaking of which, what alias should I use this time?
Oh my god, does she have a barcode?
Can I scan it?
William, I believe.
You should be able to come up with something on your own.
Oh, sorry.
Go on.
Her husband William is a researcher at a pharmaceutical company.
Despite the couple's busy schedule, they never forget to shower each other with attention.
Everyone around them speaks highly about how happy their marriage seems.
You're home.
You must have had a long day.
Yeah, my wife carries her gun with her all the time, guys.
Yeah, you too.
You must have a long day yourself.
darling not at all oh what's that honey oh these they're uh the flowers are absolutely beautiful oh right the flowers I thought you on the way home so I picked them up thank you she loves nothing more than flowers from her husband That part of the script never seems to change no matter what role I play.
Honey?
It's nothing.
Then one day, calamity befalls the couple.
A medical accident occurs at William's pharmacy.
Oh my god, did she write this fan fiction?
Like who wrote this script?
I need to know who wrote this script for us.
She is so immersed.
A medical instant accident occurs at William's pharmaceutical company.
All the blame is pinned entirely on poor William.
The couple suddenly becomes buried in debt.
And their idyllic life collapses overnight.
When she actually wrote this script.
Oh my god.
Despite this, Anna never blames William.
Instead, it's all right.
What happened?
Wasn't your fault.
fault honey it's the world that's gone crazy um if like i messed up in a pharmaceutical company that means some people might have died um but don't worry my wife doesn't think it's my fault that's okay it's the world's fault don't worry the judges will be sent from a book to guide everyone towards the end they begin to blame the world for turning its back on them Don't worry about it.
Yeah, it's not me, it's everyone else's fault.
Soon, the couple became devoted to the torch of salvation.
With their fate deepened, the couple decided to attend a gathering, reportedly being held at a certain mansion.
Wait, so, oh, I was like the fall guy.
Oh, so I was just a low-ranker.
Let's quietly head for the outer rim.
Yeah, I want to see Dee's fanfiction account.
even bring this is way too professional of a script it has like everything like backstory my likes and dislikes my like literally this her likes and dislikes my daily routine with my wife they even bring a bouquet of flowers hoping to be welcomed as initiates into the fate the residential area near the mansion is eerily quiet It's rather unsettling.
It's like there's no one around at all.
Only pages filled where prayer scripts are scattered about.
There's no sign of life anywhere.
Kay and I were digging around.
This area was crawling with cultists.
So what now, darling?
Let's start by checking out the area.
Given the situation, I think we can drop the act.
yeah yeah act act yeah of course of course the end I split up to look around well there are signs someone's living here recently the place itself is completely empty the only thing worth noting is some sort of graffiti has been scrawled all over the walls is that an umbrella wait where why would someone draw something like that there does it mean anything I stared at the umbrella graffiti for a while,
but it offers no answers.
Nike, search up umbrella corporation.
I turn my head and see the mansion looming in the distance.
And the moment I saw it, the mansion felt like it didn't belong in the outer rim.
I feel like if I don't know what it is, wouldn't there be like a Nike equivalent of a search engine?
and be like reverse image search this reverse image search by this umbrella what's a perfectly intact mansion like this doing in the other room you ask like they can invent the fountain of youth but they can't invent a find my Nikkei tracker chip where's my find my Nikkei phone app beats me yeah A strange rumor has been spreading in the outer rim.
Wuckles warns others not to go near the mansion.
Stay far away from the mansion unless you want misfortune to come your way.
Maybe that's why it's so intact.
I feel like that's the first thing I would invent to capitalize on the Nikkei's running around.
I'd be like, have you ever wondered where your Nikkei went off to?
You lost your Nikkei and you don't know where she is.
App for you.
Find my Niki.
This place gives me the creeps.
Maybe I should have head to where D is.
I'm pretty sure I saw her heading that way earlier.
D?
You here?
Sorry.
I didn't realize...
Oh!
In there?
Okay.
I didn't realize you were changing.
I am slipping something that would be easier to move around in.
Whoops.
Sorry.
My bad.
No point in pretending that we're a couple at this point.
So, did you see anything?
I noticed some strange graffiti drawn all over the place.
But, other than that, nothing unusual.
Nothing out of the ordinary?
That makes all even more suspicious.
I hear a door opening I hear a door opening behind me He has changed back into her usual outfit Hmm Doesn't look like there's anything else to learn here Let's head to the mansion If I have any luck You might find some sort of lead
Target located Ada There she is That's my girl keep up your end of the bargain and i'll do the same there she is oh my god it's her clean up neatly and beautiful oh my god wait i okay i was gonna say where's where's the rest of my team i
hey hey i don't want to look at you it's ada day get out of here it's like pushing that sheep away it's not you it's her not bad yay i did it next mission together the game knows it's only ada the mansion is heavily guarded there's no way to sneak in ada is practically my entire team the only way we can get inside without causing a scene citing this prayer to prove we are believers.
Memorize all of this from top to bottom.
And don't even think about complaining.
Again?
Look, I know that for you, you can just delete hard drive and recycle and trash, but this is a lot harder to memorize.
I spend the whole night memorizing everything.
Just as Dee had told me.
Oh my god, I'm so whipped.
Unfortunately, I never get to use what I memorized.
Contrary to what Dee told me getting into the mansion end up being extremely easy.
Yeah, I know.
She's like, it's heavily guarded.
I was like, where?
Especially since there wasn't even any security.
Wait, you lied.
Much like the residential district, the mansion is deserted.
Well, you said it was guarded.
What did I memorize?
Aside from the ominous creaking of the floorboards, under my feet absolutely nothing else could be heard looks like this place is empty too k and i scoped out the mansion surrounding only two days ago what the heck happened between then and now did they did they catch wind of us snooping around i don't know you're you're holding a giant axe i think we look very suspicious
know i feel like we sort of look very suspicious d i won't be surprised i but if that was so
d it seems whatever i'm saying now is not getting through to d i leave d to your thoughts and start surveying the lobby in the center of the lobby i step carefully past a shattered chandelier and spot a half-destroyed statue of a goddess.
The moment I approached the creepy statue, I noticed a long trail of red stains stretching down the hallway.
D, you might want to see this.
The trail of blood leads straight into the dining room.
Oh, is that where...
Maybe... Maybe Claire?
What a mess.
Or Polly?
Maybe?
You can say that again.
The dining room is in complete disarray.
We've rotten food scattered everywhere.
Yet the foul stench lingering in the air was not coming from spoiled food.
It was coming from somewhere else instead.
I'll go check it out on my own.
No, let's go together.
The blood trail winds past the dining table.
Oh, a secret, a secret entrance.
At the end of the trail?
There's a corpse.
The body has been horribly mangled.
Oh, zombies?
The blood hasn't even dried up yet.
It's clear this just happened.
Oh, what in the world is going on here?
Suddenly.
I feel something cold pressed.
Oh, that has to be Ada.
I knew it.
I could see it.
I could see the red.
Lower your weapon.
It's best you don't do anything foolish.
That is.
If you want to keep him alive.
Identify yourself.
FBI.
But I suppose you wouldn't know what that is.
Wait, is this like a...
Uh, sorry.
But who I am is classified.
I was going to say FBI.
FBI in the Niki universe?
I was like, did they like like jump from an alternate dimension?
Here's a friendly tip though.
Stop asking questions and get out of here while you still can.
Yeah, I was gonna say, did like a portal open up or something and there was like a time like a, what's the word called?
When they accidentally cross cross between dimensions a time rift or something
i was gonna i was thinking like maybe i can solo this
oh that's what the d wave is oh it pulls people from different universes into it oh i see oh so it's like yeah dimensions cross it's time i teach all of you a lesson you'll have to take it from here we got this Ada you're so good hey get out of here I don't even know you're gonna get out of here this is the Ada Wong show
yeah the D stands for doki the doki waves that's why I'm always here whenever there's a collab I am most pleased with it alright I believe finishing one five Unlocks the... Finishing 1.5 Unlocks the minigame, right?
Because I want to try the minigame out as soon as I can.
Because I heard it's really, really fun.
Hmm.
Ren, are you alright?
Hmm?
Yeah, of course.
I was just using my usual firearms check.
And this hour The work day's over.
An ACUP works for our citizens around the clock.
How is that?
Did it sound cool?
Not really.
I don't think that's something you should be seeing in this situation.
Is that so?
Cherish your gun like you would a loved one.
What about that?
It doesn't quite fit the situation either.
Oh, really?
Then...
Oh.
Darn, this isn't good.
Officially out of excuses!
Hang on.
We're not planning on waiting until I'm off duty and then heading to the other rim, are you?
The boss already told us.
Since there's no way HQ is ever going to authorize an investigation, we've been told to stand by for now.
Are you still investigating, aren't you, Query?
Well, Query quickly shuts the file folder she's carrying.
Document she was reading is late.
Oh, that's the Polly case.
I can't sit and do nothing.
but I have to head out to the outer rim to find Polly.
But we be defying orders.
Find by Mimi.
No Niki left behind.
I've gotten used to filling out disciplinary reports.
10 pages.
Damn.
I mean six pages.
No, three pages.
I can fill that out in my sleep.
I think we'd be in for more than just a disciplinary report.
Oh, even better.
Then I won't have to write one at all.
No, and what I'm saying is...
Besides, Polly would have done the same for us.
Hurry turns the white bard, placed in the corner of the police station.
Her vision is too blurry to make out what's written on it.
But the photo of Polly pinned at the center of the board stood out perfectly clear to her.
All right, I'm off.
Miranda, yes, I'm coming with you.
Yay, teamwork makes the dream work.
So, what's our first course of action?
Oh, are you asking me?
Just you and me, so who else would I be asking?
And no more jumping out of shadows like last time, okay?
It honestly scared me to death when you do.
So what you're telling me is you came out of here without a plan?
Well, this is where Polly's...
Oh, there it is!
Find my Niki!
I knew it!
I was like, how could they not have that?
There it is!
And then the family died.
This is where Polly's signal was last detected.
Oh, why don't we start searching around this area?
Also, is it just me, or does this place feel kind of creepy?
This isn't raising a soul around.
I hate it when my phone runs out of battery so you can't find my neat game.
Hey, do you see that?
There's a mansion over there.
Let's check it out.
This is the ACUP.
We're coming in.
Moran and Yanks open the front door and stride confidently through.
Oh, we really shouldn't be barging.
Oh my gosh, he's scared.
You are in the police force.
You have a rocket as a gun.
We should really...
Shouldn't be...
Be paging in like this.
ACOP open up.
As the front door opened.
She has a rocket!
Has a gun!
Why is she scared?
What's that?
She couldn't be any more prepared for this situation.
Encouraged hazy field of vision.
shapes appear.
Is it the dogs?
That's not, that's not Polly!
Oh my god, evil dogs.
Three dogs lunges towards them.
Their eyes glow as sinister red as if infected by something.
Where did it come from?
Woof, woof.
Uh, just as the largest one appears, it's jaws.
Bang.
Oh, it's chilling.
Did they shoot that dog?
Two women appear from behind.
Bang, bang.
One of them fires a launch.
What?
Okay, no.
They caught.
Okay, never mind.
They shot the air.
I was like, not the dogs.
They were about to kill them, but not the dogs.
Oh.
You okay?
Thanks a bunch.
But who are you?
I should be asking you the same thing.
What the hell is this place?
And who are you people?
Is that a rocket for a gun?
I will...
I cannot get over the fact that she's literally holding a giant-ass rocket.
I feel like Jill and Claire should be more concerned about that.
Be like, what is that?
Like, what are you holding?
Yay!
Kablui!
My little mermaid did it.
I knew I could always count on you.
Hold the door.
We gotta keep them out.
Oh my gosh, we're in our little...
safe room okay wolf wolf wolf
damn another mansion am I caught in a nightmare ow don't worry I just pinched my cheek and it definitely don't it's like you have an idea no I just know it's not a dream That means this is no nightmare But you're still not convinced I can pinch your cheek too if you like And Joe's just like Oh my god She's just like I saved them
That's so thoughtful I can't tell if she's like Sarcastic or not I can't tell I'm you're most welcome can we save the banter for later
park wolf wolf wolf wolf wolf wolf the
family should The shaking door finally stops.
It's feeding time!
I think they're all gone now.
I thought the gunfire scared some of them off, but they brought friends instead.
They're like, we rolled up with reinforcements!
Woof!
If we arrived any later, things could have been a disaster.
Yeah, that was too close for comfort.
He wants his food.
Anyway, now that things have calmed down, let's get some proper introduction going.
I'm Claire.
Claire Redfield.
I'm Quarry from...
Oh, it's ACPU.
I was thinking of ICUP.
I...
I was like, damn, we changed one letter in the ICUP.
But it's ACPU.
You.
Okay.
ACPU.
I was like, A cup.
Thanks for your help.
And this here is I'm Miranda.
Also with the A cup.
ACPU.
The ACPU?
That's right.
We're the police safeguarding citizens.
that's what the ACPU does so you're both police officers then have you heard of a man called Chris he really likes punching boulders you can't miss him he's my he's my brother he works for the Raccoon City Police Department I haven't been able to reach him so I've been looking for him the Raccoon City Police department border I'm not too sure have you heard of that query no this is my first time hearing about this department seems close for this man Chris I see it's a pity
my introduction um yeah and you are names Jill Jill Valentine Claire and Jill got it can exactly can I ask exactly how you two ended up here Mimi thank you for the raid oh yeah that great stream I'm just checking out the new Resident Evil collab with Niki right now I got sponsored
well yeah so you see like jill and claren in here now or in the nike universe i realize how crazy this probably sounds but i'm curious about that myself oh i was in a chopper getting evacuated from raccoon city when everything went blurry next thing i knew i was here wait so the the the what's
Literally, like, absorbed the entire mansion.
You too?
I was trying to escape Raccoon City when everything started going blurry too.
Or D-Wave.
Before I knew it, I saw two of them getting attacked.
I just reacted and sprang into action.
What the hell happened to us?
Alright.
the minigame unlocked now?
Enter.
Oh, wait, back.
It's so dark in here.
Oh, hey, there's Quarry.
Oh, there it is.
The broken golden goddess statue.
I assume this is the minigame.
Also, sleazy.
Thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you.
D-Wave.
A series of disappearance.
N.
Torch of salvation.
I have to uncover the connection between these three.
Confirm the identities of the missing, and if possible, rescue them.
Yeah, I heard the...
I heard this minigame is, like, super addicting.
This is the mission that brought me here to this old mansion and the outer rim.
Alright.
I'm going in.
Okay.
Creak.
The front gates open to reveal The courtyard Thick fog Blankens the area Making it hard to see the surroundings
Creepy Think so Not so good We are like in an abandoned mansion I don't know what scares you then We literally saw a dead body what was what screech did you hear that Dee not really aren't you being too jumpy is that so I'll keep moving
maybe it's because I'm at the mansion that the torch of salvation uses as their base Keep King sounds like a rapture is nearby.
Alright.
Somewhere inside this thick fog.
A rapture really is roaming around.
One of the missing people.
Maybe running from a rapture.
Or even fighting one right now.
I just hope that's not the case.
I was like, did you not hear the screaming people?
Oh!
Okay.
Let's look at the tutorial.
Okay, let's not look at the tutorial.
Let's just go in.
Submachine gun.
Continuous fire fires a large number of bullets dealing damage to enemies.
Initiates continuous bombing dealing damage.
Okay, okay.
I can only be...
Oh, I guess I have to unlock the others later.
Oh, available after.
Okay, it's later on.
Alright.
tutorial done.
I know what to do.
It's a mini-game where you merge and upgrade weapons to stop incoming monsters.
Efficiency, efficiently upgrade your characters in the shop.
That appears after wave ends or through trait schedules.
Wave and monsters.
Monsters come in waves.
And you must survive a total of 99 waves.
99!
Oh my.
Okay.
That's fine.
We can do this.
Oh!
Tetris!
Bumparadom The shop opens after a wave Ends It consists of two sections Inventory weapons You can manage your inventory management Weapons can be freely moved Between the inventory and weapons selections As long as your size does not exceed the inventory Inventory capacity There are two types of weapons Weapons and sub-weapons Tap the weapon view icon to view the weapon info Alright Remove all weapons in section and replace them With fixed number of new it and their weapons and once all free profit are used um oh oh my god oh my oh my god you can scroll down oh okay all right okay now okay that makes a lot more sense i was like uh i didn't really scroll down i was like what the where does the sentence come from Drop weapons ship.
I don't know.
I thought it was just...
This is the next phase.
Weapons place will be used in battles.
Inventory is in battle.
And the weapon is where I refresh it.
I can merge them.
Okay.
Stacking weapons of the same type.
Can merge and become stronger weapons.
Okay.
I mean...
I might as well...
just
uh increases xp oh there you go all right merge i merged the gun all right start battle
boom all right how do i shoot my gun guys wait
my gun not shooting what why is oh it's auto okay okay that thank god i was a little worried i was like excuse me what why is gun not shoot i got scared i got really scared what is this deal i hear stories every hundred of the okay nice i think that's fine i'm even for five.
I got very scared.
I was like, guys, you're getting closer.
I don't think we need to use the special yet.
Defeating monsters earn a certain amount.
Oh, it's like a roguelike.
Earn a certain amount of XP to conduct upgrades.
When leveling up, you can select traits that provide different effects.
Traits are divided in phase one and two.
By default, three options are presented.
a same type can be owned while unique traits can also be obtained once per game okay
okay oh yeah it's a roguelike oh my god that's i love roguelikes increase the ot duration decreases normal attack reload time by three percent okay i feel like xp is always important
XP is always important in my early game.
Early games should always, like, look into XP.
Uh...
I don't know.
Let's see.
210.
55.
Wait, what?
Wait, this gun is better.
55?
Yeah, this attack is 210.
That's so much.
What?
I merge this?
Can I only merge that once?
Oh, it only fires a single bullet?
Oh, it increases the number of bullets fired per shot.
Oh, I did have that same color merge.
I see.
Oh, no.
I feel like I'm going to try this for now.
ditch the toolkit it's toolkit not that important i thought you'd be more important yeah but if i ditch the toolkit i can't even put this gun i'm gonna do two nades let's use two nades oh
not this early i see aoe attack first skill Am I using eye grenades?
We'll do that.
I feel like that's important right now.
Oh.
I'll expand here.
Actually...
What
is that here?
Oh!
Let's see.
Okay.
Yeah, I'll do it here.
There we go.
Fire bullets in a fan shape dealing damage to enemies.
Is this better?
I'll do this.
What does this do again?
Oh, increases XP.
We need more XP.
I can't fuse them.
Yeah, it can't be merged.
Alright, start battle.
It has to be...
I don't mind.
I'm going to do XP just because I feel like XP is always important in early game.
Um, when I play Rogue Lights.
Uh.
There you go.
There's a level cap.
Oh, nice.
What's this?
Oh my god.
Alright.
we'll grab knockback too
all right uh
nice I'm pretty good at this I say as I'm only on wave 6 I can tell why this can get dictating these are like my rabbit hole to addiction
I have shotgun so I feel like this would be good but this is okay I I would do 5% over regular reload.
I love roguelikes.
I like, it's actually like, for me it's a problem.
I get so addicted to roguelikes in general.
Oh, needle.
With mild side effects, the greases the barricade HP by tube.
That's fine.
I'm not too worried about that.
I think that's fine.
That's nothing too scary.
scary for me.
Let's start it.
I feel like I should use this when the boss shows up.
I feel like, yeah, normal attack.
This is not scary yet.
I feel like I need cooldown, cooldown, or speed.
What the heck?
What is this?
Assault rifle.
Is assault rifle good?
Compared to what?
what I have right now.
I'll have to get, I mean, I could get rid of this and put this in, but is it worth it?
That's the thing.
So I can figure this out.
No, it's not.
I'm like thinking if it's worth keeping this gun pistol, it's better to ditch the pistol.
No, you can't rotate them.
Which is better?
This, uh...
Put the rifle in the bottom spot.
I don't think I can...
No.
I think it's better here.
Yeah.
Is assault...
AR is better than SMG?
Okay.
We'll try this then.
I didn't even get another XP.
I'll invest in XP.
And then...
Oh, range, actually.
I'll do range because it's Urple.
I invest on anything that's purple.
Urple, good.
Okay, XP.
I wish I can stockpile this.
Oh, wait, nice, I can.
Hee-hee.
What if double pistol?
Alright, nice.
I can merge the metals.
Oh, no.
Two urples!
Oh, wait.
I don't have anything for that.
I have to do any of it.
I was like, oh my god, two urples!
But I was like, wait, I don't even have any of these guns.
Nice.
That's good.
We haven't had to use.
There hasn't been like...
I feel like this It's not worth it
I'm thinking if I should merge here
Hmm I'm thinking about like
I should do that Yeah I'm thinking about gun shapes right now too That's the thing
I need this Yeah I think I should do that so then i can move that here and down here
might be a little dumb what i did but it's okay it might be a little dumb what oh critical rate i was like what what does that do
ah it is a little dumb it might have been a little dumb but
I want The silencer is good But we're not with the metal then
Move the grenade down
Yeah, but then we lose this gun
We do this Oops
Oh, this sucks
Oh, JK I'm so good at this JK Bump on bump
I'm so good at this.
Plan.
Yeah, I don't even know what I put in.
Increases.
Okay, barricade HP.
Big brain.
Instead turn around.
It fits.
Okay, normal damage.
I'll wait for this to get a bit closer.
or I use it.
Actually, I don't even have to use it.
We're just good.
Grab that.
That's purple.
Damage by 15%.
This is 5.
So we'll get the purple.
Oh, I would love to keep the grenade, but I have no slots.
Should I refresh it?
Is it worth?
it?
Yeah, it was.
It was so worth it.
There we go.
Describe the barricade?
There's no reason for me to discard it because I don't have a slot for anything anyway.
Like, I can't fit anything in here if I discard it.
Unless I like okay, if I move this down.
Yeah, there's no reason.
I don't think I...
Oh wait, I can.
There you go.
I have the weirdest suitcase.
If there's another EXP, I'll go grab it.
That's exactly what I wanted.
Everything always goes according to plan.
My brain is expanding.
It's optimizing.
Oh my god.
What is this?
Oh.
Oh, no, that's blue.
Oh, my God.
How do I fit this?
Is this good?
Is it worth it?
Flamethrower good?
I meant to get rid of the shotgun.
But...
It's fire!
Yeah, but I'm losing these.
I'm losing my other shotgun.
So I'm like, fuck it.
I'll remove all of this, but I'll do it.
I think that's the...
I think that's the only way.
Oh my god.
I don't even know if they can get there.
Get close enough.
I just realized I was like, And they even let...
What's this?
What's DOT?
It's purple.
I feel like...
What's DOT?
Damage over time?
Do I have weapons that do damage over time?
Do I even have weapons that do damage over time?
Burning damage?
Okay, we'll do that then.
I just don't know if I have weapons.
that does it.
So I'm, like, worried if it's worth it or not.
I can't believe it's, like, 99 rounds.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
So I can move this up.
Oh.
I don't need the pistol, right?
Is shotgun better than the pistol?
Chat.
Wait for a blue pistol?
Okay.
yeah shotgun's better right versus a pistol yeah okay let's start with this i want more xp i feel like it just be better okay or like range of the flamethrower i think maybe but how did i get how did i not oh my god
is it worth that i feel like i'm gonna die i feel like
I don't know Gold is good I'm just like I feel like if I do this I die This is my first try
You have to It's gold Take Green More XP But I'm doing so well Okay Okay.
Alright, I'm taking that risk.
I'm taking that risk, guys.
Oh my god, is that...
That's not the enhanced, right?
Surely it won't...
Surely it won't fuck me over, right?
Nah.
It'll be fine.
But it's gone!
God!
It'll be okay.
Everything will be fine.
It'll be fine.
I don't think I need to use it.
I want to use it for emergencies.
It hasn't been an emergency yet.
I don't have any of these.
Oh!
Blast zone?
Duration or AoE attack?
Two?
One or two.
Oh yeah, I know.
It's for a fire, a flamethrower.
Two?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, now I know how.
Okay, they're getting too close to your right.
Should I be smiling?
I think I might need a repair kit.
I think maybe.
I don't know.
Yeah, but I have no space.
where to fit it i
can't fit it anywhere there's
nowhere for it to go but
i i worked so hard
i worked so hard for the shotgun oh
my god this is hard
keep the shotgun drop the ar isn't that bad Is the AR worse than a shotgun?
Okay.
All right, we'll go with this.
What if I just use it here?
All right.
Grab that.
Oh my god, big boy is coming.
Oh my god, oh my god, please.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Guys, why did we press gold?
Why?
Oh shit, why did guys, guys, why did we, why did we pick gold?
Why did we pick gold?
He's so strong.
Okay, we might have fucked up by picky gold.
We might have messed up.
Okay.
Crisis up, brooded.
I could grab another of this.
Or do I grab the SMG?
Keep shoddy for a gold chance?
Keep shotgun?
I can reroll.
Oh, nice.
Oh, hey, sniper.
Limbs are where we're snip- I mean, I can refresh again.
We have a lot of gold, right?
We have so much gold.
I just realized What
am I doing?
I've just done this Grabbed their pistol
Their pistol I don't think we need a shotgun So invest in the Pistol
For upgrades later What kind of upgrades later Because
I'm a little worried That I might have messed up Because Okay now Wait, all right, EXP?
EXP or pierce damage?
Or burst?
One, two, or three?
One?
Okay, burst damage is nice.
Okay, I'll go with burst.
I'll give you stars!
Oh my god.
When is 30?
Okay, thank god.
Okay, I was gonna say when is it 30 seconds?
Oh.
None of these are good upgrades.
I'm thinking.
No.
It moves the sniper up.
Not really.
There's no reason to.
So it doesn't really matter.
It doesn't change anything.
I don't think it I think it was okay here wait where did I have it here here and then I think I'll keep I don't know I don't know if I want the pistol or the SMG I want pistol or SMG I can't tell
you want ditch if we ditch the silencer I'll
keep it like this
I do not have a lot of HP I see it.
Oh, it does what plus 1% It's my side did more
I don't know BXB gain or
Do I do one or two?
Grenade stun.
Oh, grenade stun, you're right.
I forgot about that
Okay Okay Okay, nice.
Oh, nice.
That's actually so good.
We got so many weapon upgrades from that.
Yeah, a debuff was definitely better.
Oh, my God.
Why did I click the gold?
Why did I...
Oh, why did I click the gold?
Oh, my God.
They're getting so close.
They're getting closer.
Oh, my poor.
My poor wall.
My wall is getting closer.
So messed up.
Two or three.
This is my euphorus.
Numbers must go up no matter the cost.
Greed is good.
If it's...
If Greed is good, why is it a deadly sin?
Why?
What do you mean?
Oh, my poor wall.
My poor wall.
I don't know where else to put this.
Okay, I sort of have an idea.
Is that fine?
Yeah.
What the heck is this?
Oh, laser cannon.
I was like, what?
Is the laser cannon good?
Oh my god, okay I need to figure this out
Oh my god I
Oh my, what did I do?
What did I do?
Okay
Oh, what did I do?
Okay, there you go I fixed it
Okay, there you go I think... I've...
I've...
Fixed it.
I did it.
That's fine.
I think.
There we go.
We're fine.
I fixed it.
Everything looks okay.
I'll give you stars!
Oh my god, I'm a little stressed out.
They're getting a lot closer.
I'm getting stressed out.
They're getting awfully close to me.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
AOE attack.
Damage.
We're okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh, we got a couple of upgrades.
That's good.
that's fine we got several upgrades too
oh my god what happened to my footer oh my god oh my god what's going on with us oh my god okay okay okay it's okay we okay okay it's okay okay it's okay it's okay he's That's okay.
It's okay.
He's just slowly walking forward.
He might be slowly walking.
We're okay.
We're, we're, we're okay.
And he's very menacingly walking.
I feel like I'm going to refresh because I feel like this is the end of days right now.
All right, that was useless.
Okay, that's fine.
That was...
Oh, I wanted a barricade.
Oh, why don't I have a barricade?
All right.
Oh, my God.
Why did I press gold?
Why did I increase their damage?
Oh my god, no!
Oh no!
Everything's okay.
I don't know.
Yes, okay, like this.
And then...
Okay, here.
Guys, green might not be good.
Guys, I think...
day I learned.
Greed might not be good.
It's crazy.
I know.
It's a crazy concept.
But greed may be bad.
Greed bad.
That can't be, right?
You sure.
I don't know where to put the laser.
Here and then
laser top right like this
that has to seem right
hmm metal upper left here yeah but what do I do here then
oh there you go yay!
Oh my god okay this works we did it this is the true this is the actual true puzzle I don't think we're living.
I don't know.
It's looking awfully rough for Jokey Bird right now.
It's looking awfully bad right now for Jokey Bird.
Oh my god.
Oh my very poor barricade.
Um, oh my god.
Okay.
Let's do a normal attack.
I have some machine gun shot.
We don't need gold.
We don't need gold Okay
Oh, man Oh, man Oh, I'm refreshing.
I have so much gold.
Oh, man.
Why did I refresh?
Okay, but what if I refresh one more time?
Oh my god, I need to stop.
Why did I keep doing it?
I thought it'd be different.
I thought like something different will happen.
Keep traveling.
I don't know.
I thought it'd be a different result for some reason.
Clearly I was wrong.
Oh, why?
Why did I do that?
that why did I make for it oh my god why did I have to make this harder for myself oh my god oh this
is a nookie so good
three oh my poor barricade oh my poor little
Oh, oh, oh, maybe I'll give you a barricade.
Why?
I keep thinking something different will happen, but it's still the same.
I keep thinking something different will happen.
Why do I still have one barricade?
Do not take that AR.
okay oh my guys i don't think my little bear king is gonna live past the sick guys i just doesn't look so good i think they're winning i think umbrella's gonna win oh my god please please five percent three oh i'm
one i'm one hp i'm one hp i guess i don't okay we have one more in life okay we'll just do this
cool unless we up here so we can push everything up a little too i think we're so cooked anyway it really doesn't matter what i do i i think we're it's it's we're so cooked i don't think it matters
why does it not give me like like I don't understand one more refresh wouldn't hurt right no no no I have two HP it doesn't matter guys I have two HP I don't I think what happened was that I should not have taken the I should not have taken the one where they're like why don't you make it make your thing like make the boss's hat harder like that was my mistake oh my god that was because i have to do one more i have okay i figured it out i figured it also if you've been if you want trying this game out you can click on the link pinned in my chat and pin in my chat my description it'll really help out a lot but yeah check out dk because guys now i understand that we got A little greedy,
but now, now I know.
Guys, now it's over.
We got this.
Stay sharp, everyone.
Oh, wait, I can upgrade for upgrades now?
Wait, quick end.
How does it feel?
A return.
Oh, I didn't realize.
I forgot yet.
I forgot that this is the rogue.
Like, oh my god, this is how people get to the end game.
Grab this.
What do we upgrade?
Okay, high-grade weapons, most likely.
We're not getting enhanced monsters.
Oh, great.
XP.
Attack.
Yeah, I'll do damage XP and weapons.
Oh my god, there was more.
What do you mean?
There was barricade HP.
Okay, wait.
Let's get rid of.
Why do I never go to look down?
out all right it's fine we don't need it okay this this this and this
we're out oh not enough gold this is fine now we'll have enough all right we'll do one more oh my i should have such good rng though
oh my god
this is the official run
okay I'll leave the shoddy I don't think we need shotgun
okay now we know do not get do not make the monsters harder despite it being yellow don't do it now I know guys I see yellow.
But gold.
Gold is good.
Is that what you said?
I don't know.
Pistol is good, right?
Pistol is better than shotgun and sniper, right?
But what?
Gold equals more gold.
Don't keep but the points, though.
Pistol, alright.
We'll go with pistol.
Sniper.
is bis sniper for later it's fine oh gold
oh one two or three chat think about that money think about the gold
one all right pew pew pew We got grenades now.
Pew pew pew pew.
All right.
I'll do the XP.
Chili.
Two or three.
I feel like X...
Always choose damage.
Oh, okay.
That'll do three.
Make a square.
I have two grenades now.
Yeah, that's fine.
Oh, EXP early is good?
People are saying there's a level cap though.
There's a level cap so there's no point.
Grab that, it's purple.
It's taking EXP do it very early.
All right.
So I feel like...
Oh, EXP is harder to get later.
Oh, okay.
Why the fuck would I get the third one?
Alright, if I get another XP thing, I'll take it.
Knock back.
If I see another XP one, I'll take it.
Uh...
Hmm...
Oh, this is difficult.
Oh...
I don't know if they can fit anything in here.
Yeah.
I can't fit anything.
I'll give you stars.
I'll just use all of this now.
Alright.
My record.
What was my record?
Ooh.
Damage.
Go like that.
Oh, nice.
I created this just for that.
Damage.
More grenades.
25 okay wait 25 was my record I'll give you stars a 9,000 points okay I gotta get I think I'm gonna look at waves not points I'll give you stars pierce attack damage I don't really ah I feel like I don't have a lot of night I don't have a sniper so I feel like I should just do normal attack damage
just a warning though upgrading enemies while giving you more xp money and score would definitely yeah no i don't worry i i definitely experienced that i don't don't worry i know that all too well i i have plenty of experience with that unfortunately we figured that out
We may or may not have figured it out the very, very hard way.
No,
this is useful for me.
I feel like I just don't have space.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's worth just...
I'm just gonna wait until I have more space.
I think it's worth keeping.
All these guns are just...
I'll grab the UXP.
Greed is good in moderation.
Think about what to do.
Wait, just do that.
But I don't know.
I don't know how to expand this.
I can push this here.
How many...
Like this?
This is a shotgun shape, right?
Was it like this, chat?
was it like this
and now I can move this here too and then push all this down
oh hey nice this that's actually what we need it
very convenient I wonder if I could like push this here and then put it here or would that be like pointless alright that's good speak of the devil We got a shotgun.
Grab the second one.
And then I'll do, like, damage again.
I'll give you stars.
I wanted to use it for this guy.
Because he's like, warning, warning.
I was like, warning, warning.
Okay.
Normal attack reload time.
Alright, one, two, or three?
Three?
See, ones and three.
Uh, I see more one.
Okay, I'll do one.
Ah, fuck, okay.
I know if laser is worth the investment.
I'll refresh it.
And nice, that's actually what we needed, too.
Alright, nice.
That's what we needed.
That was a good risk.
Calculated.
Yeah.
That refresh actually was so helpful.
Doesn't matter.
I don't have space for this pistol.
Doesn't matter!
Do we want damage increase?
Should we keep that for the damage increase or?
I don't know we can move anything around to fit anything.
Everything is so weirdly...
3% isn't worth Alright, let's do that then If it's not worth it, I'll keep the pistol for the upgrade
Alright, 1, 2 We don't have a lot of snipers, so it's like 2 or 3
3 2 or 3 I see more 3, so I'll go with 3 It's like cooldown reduction, right?
3 is cooldown reduction, right?
Assume that makes it better.
Okay.
Let's make another gun.
I just make two guns.
My two small pistols.
We'll do that.
And then I do that.
And then swap this here.
And then this over there.
And then...
I'll do that here in case I have a big gun.
Actually...
Hmm.
that here lower that down too memorize it guys I can see the guns right here I don't need a memorized gun patterns I see it right here guys
get the right you're like wow I can't believe you guys no I can I have the guns on my screen chat i know what it looks like guys i'm not that i swear i'm not that stupid
uh i'll do it here so like if we get like a shotgun we put it here too oh see look at that it worked out it actually worked out nice okay my original plan was to move this here okay Okay, actually, we could just put this here.
I actually worked out.
I would like to put...
Hmm.
That's fine.
Refresh for pistol.
I can try.
It's fine.
We got this, though.
I can fit that in.
How?
No.
I don't think so.
It's pretty full.
I bet this in.
Grenade bottom left.
But where would we put the toolkit then?
We don't need critical rate, right?
Yeah?
Like this?
Alright.
Toolkit is my baby, guys.
No, don't say that.
Shh.
Toolkit.
They don't mean that.
Shh.
The dragons don't.
mean that all
right one one or three that don't they don't mean that toolkit you're doing a great job you're the carry of the family i'll give you stars okay toolkits gonna be the mvp guys just you wait holy shit I just like upgrade 20 things at once
there you know
all right we upgraded so many things at once there oh it's like the game got a lot easier after when I don't take like the death upgrades that's crazy I'll give you stars okay
we just need one two more blues for this i don't even know if it's worth getting the adr i don't think it's worth it if i do a refresh i could get two shotguns
nah or i could get a blue shotgun
or pistol yeah let's go gambling okay um i might grab another grenade if i hit like all right i already gambled it's too late it's technically free gambling if you think about it you could get a ledge oh never mind oh no oh no oh no he's coming daddy is coming right here knockback.
I feel like knockback's always good.
Oh my god, you're getting closer.
He's getting closer.
Oh my god, he's getting so close.
Oh my god, it's fine.
Hmm.
Yeah, see, the toolkit clutched it.
At the bottom, I could.
Oh, nice.
How was... Okay, I was gonna say
Stop that.
Fuck it.
I just got a better grenade.
Hmm.
That's fine.
Yeah, it looks good.
We're almost there.
See, look at that!
We're back to 100!
I told you.
See, toolkit?
They were wrong about you.
I knew you wouldn't disappoint me.
I knew you were going to be the clutch of the family.
Oh my god, barricade.
There we go.
We just need...
That was a good decision for me.
Because I could get blue and then max it out.
Nice.
See?
I got good reroll
I find it funny that yesterday I was playing a roguelike a roguelike survivor game and then we're back they knew they knew I have they knew my addiction
last reroll that's worth it It was a very calculative risk.
There you go.
She's doing so good when she's not actively injuring herself.
You don't understand!
It was gold!
It glowed yellow!
Yellow equals good!
I'll give you stars
We'll do that here But You look good You look Not good
Hmm We don't need that pistol We can try and aim for an AR upgrade Uh Okay guys Is Pistol or AR What is better?
AR?
Okay, well, we'll aim for AR upgrades then.
I mean, they're both great, so it doesn't really matter to me.
Ew!
I'll give you stars!
Wait, does two pistols not...
I'll do the OE.
We have a lot of grenades and stuff anyway.
Wait, that is like...
Can you not use more than one pistol?
If I have two pistols...
Oh, you can't stack.
Okay, I was gonna say like, what?
What's the point then?
Like, I was like, excuse me, what do you mean I can't stack?
Okay.
I'm thinking right now.
I just need another blue grenade.
It's fine.
We'll start here.
Oh, no.
I didn't realize.
Oh, my God.
You serious?
I didn't realize they sent in the big boys.
Oh, okay.
It's okay.
My toolkit's gonna come in clutch.
My toolkit is coming in clutch.
Look at it.
Oh, okay.
Don't worry.
It's gonna fix.
He's gonna fix him.
He's gonna fix it.
There we go.
Aoe time.
Reload.
I'll grab gold.
See, I told you.
I told you it comes in.
Oh my god.
Okay, we can have blue at least for this.
I'll just use once.
I mean, I can get this at least.
I really want to grab this, but it doesn't matter.
The little toolkit that could.
Ah.
Move the gold coin up and the laser over.
What?
I want to grab this, but...
I have no space.
Alright, I don't think I can keep it.
It's fine.
I haven't found another coin yet.
Oh no.
Okay.
Alright.
This is fine.
We're slowly healing it all.
Don't worry.
The toolkit that could hit.
I'll grab the pierce.
I think it's worth it now.
Grab that here.
So at least I can make this here.
Trying to expand my brain.
Okay, I put this here.
Put this here.
And then I'll put this here.
There you go.
Oh, wait.
The moment I beat this wave, I beat my record.
Okay, I'm still healing everything.
Okay, nice.
I'm a lot healthier than before.
Even though they're getting through, I'm still a lot healthier than before.
Healthy is healthy, guys.
Healthy is healthy.
I can't This is so bad Okay That was not The risk wasn't worth it Oh the upgrade isn't worth it I actually need more inventory space
Yeah there's nothing worthwhile
Come on keep giving stars Keep giving stars, Jill!
I'll give you stars!
Keep doing it!
You got this!
Okay, nice.
She kept giving stars.
There's nothing.
I...
One more refresh.
Oh!
Okay, goodbye, blue.
Oh, I need to...
I should keep that blue, though.
I could make another gold.
Is it worth?
it?
Making another gold?
Ah.
Alright.
This is hard.
This is like, I can make another gold gun.
It's so rough decisions.
AOE.
That's purple.
Purple good.
Oh my god.
Tock it.
Please.
You got the 69.
Nice.
No!
Heal!
Tock it!
Alright, we can move these here.
This up.
This here.
No, actually...
God, all these suck.
They all suck!
There's nothing to do.
That's okay.
The toolkit can heal.
Look at that.
One at a time.
Oh, come on.
Just don't let them get any closer.
Oh.
Purple.
Oh, my God.
I'm halfway.
I'm half HP.
Oh, my God.
They're getting closer.
Token.
The token.
That good.
Oh.
Okay, we have more nades.
More nades.
Oh, this might be the last.
Guys, this might be it.
This might be it.
This is where we might have to oh, seven.
I don't think the toolkit can out heal anymore.
I...
Oh, wait, gold.
Oh, my God.
They're still coming.
Maybe I can survive one more round.
I can survive one more round.
We survived one more round.
We have gold pistol.
It's doable.
It is.
It is absolutely doable.
Spend it on now.
I believe.
Why did I not get another toolkit?
okay okay i don't know yes it's looking a little rough just a little bit okay plus we're 12 hp we're we're living oh my god they're getting very close
holy shit okay
I'll grab this.
I don't think that Pierce is gonna do anything for us.
Oh, one, two, one, two, oh!
Um, I realized I never got the XP thing.
I don't think it's gonna help us.
I don't think it's gonna do anything.
Alright, zero HP and a dream.
Let's go.
They just gotta poke me one time.
And it's over
It's okay Oh
We broke our We broke our record though Our record was 80k thousand points And wave 22 I mean for like barely any upgrades I think that's pretty good I think that's pretty good for This is that was actually really fun I really enjoyed it on the damage EXP Maybe inventory and then HP We gotta get more weapons
That's fun I had yeah I will say the toolkit took us there okay guys if it wasn't for our buddy toolkit We wouldn't have made it this far We wouldn't have made it that far okay guys
but oh my and i know why people were saying the uh the mini game was super addicting yeah i i really really like the mini game i think the it's definitely my favorite part uh my favorite part of the event um because i love roguelikes i i am like obsessed and addicted to roguelike survivors so um like it's it's very dangerous for me
It's very dangerous.
But yeah.
I definitely enjoyed.
I really enjoyed this event.
The Resident Evil Niki collab.
But yeah, huge shout out again.
And thank you to Niki for the sponsor.
If you guys want to try out the game yourself as well.
Feel free to click on the link pinned in the chat.
As well as in the description.
It really does help out a lot.
yeah um feel free to download the game enjoy it they're very like um they're very what's the word what's the word they're they spoil you a lot with free stuff so uh go check the game out as well you get a lot of free gems a lot of free characters to try out and everything uh they really do spoil you a lot with it and they're very generous yeah they're very generous uh with these type of the currency and stuff uh but like i said huge shout out and thank you to nike for the sponsor i had a fun great time playing i really love um the mini game i've been enjoying the story um i hope i get to know what happened up holy uh i'm pretty sure i'm i'm pretty sure we'll find find your nike we'll find her we will find her we will find our nike uh But yes,
I'm going to call it here.
That passed by so fast, too.
I can't believe I was like...
I think I was in the mini-game for like an hour or so, just because I was just so addicted to it.
But anyway, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
Before we go...
I think like...
I want to check out Jill and Claire real quick, by the way, guys.
um just because uh we didn't get to check out we only checked out ada so i want to check them up real quick jee it's not just the virus that's dangerous whoa cute raccoon city used to be what costumes did she get oh what oh she gets this one that's so cool
that's a chibi oh a battle all right let's look at it real quick too.
Yeah, she gets the, she gets that outfit for her.
Claire.
I just realized I was like, wait, I didn't get to look at them.
Now the Neovirus.
If you've seen infected.
Oh, I will never.
Oh, she's never casting yet.
Oh, wait, is that a grenade launcher?
I was like, come on.
Shoot your gun.
Do it.
I was like, come on, Claire.
Shoot your gun oh she's so cute she's really cute but yeah thank you again this is a really great collab i love the mini game my favorite part um sorry seemed pretty enjoyable but anyways i'll see you guys next time everybody you think you get the neat game please click on the link and download the game and try the game yourself i think you get really addicted to the mini game um anyway guys see everyone bye I should keep talking or else I might forget how to speak